Note, to make matters slightly more confusing,
JavaScript allows you to assign to variables you've never even declared before.
In this example I took the var statement off of this assignment operation.
So foil has not been declared anywhere in our whole program.
When you do this kind of assignment, variables that you're assigning to for
the first time will be added automatically to the global scope, and
not to whatever scope you did the assignment in.
This is actually a pretty bad practice because leaving the var keyword off
is more often done by accident than on purpose.
Even if you do purposefully decide that you want to do this,
it'll be very confusing for other people reading your code and
they'll probably assume you just made a mistake.
Also note, that unlike a lot of other languages,
not all curly braces in Java Script are relevant for scoping.
Blocks on if statements or while statements and
other looping constructs like that, do not create new scopes.
Only the curly braces that you find on a function statement creates a scope.
Scoping limitations are actually very useful.
They allow us to think about less of our program all at once.
So we don't want to subvert them by leaving off var declarations.
So for now, just remember to declare every variable with a var
keyword in whichever lexical scope you want that variable to live.